i love that story about um you two guys
you you were playing ross perot dana
and you were also playing george bush
it was a sketch you were playing both
characters
and they said to david go up and they
dressed him up as ross perrault right
david and they they sent you out there
and you thought you were playing ross
perot but it turned out
but this is a real raw nerve yeah
is it a raw nerve good talk about the
wrong nerve between you well just for
the technical part on the wide shot i'd
be overdoing george bush senior phil
would be bill clinton but on the wide
shot we needed someone to look like ross
perot was still there some extra so
david and i are similar size people but
it was the most miserable i'd seen david
i went out and he's sitting in the
corner he's got the ross pro thing on
here
he's slumped in a chair he's got the
bald cap on he has no lines he's one of
the funniest people in the world you
know so it's kind of like it was pretty
amazing it was for the the thursday
night like political special on prime
time so it was like a debate so i
thought oh
i'm so stupid dan had already done it
and they're like well he i thought well
he guess they can't do both so they go
spade we need you to do paro and i was
like [ __ ] i was literally like
practicing you weren't practicing i
didn't know sickening sickening can i
get a little bit of it kind of kind of
what are you doing
couldn't you have just said to them
can't you get some kid to stand here and
be ross i didn't get it until
it was not happening so i did the ball
cap i got out there we all did the wide
shot dana did his thing filled in his
and then they go cut thanks david go
back to extras holding and then i change
into ross i go out we pass in the
hallway and i just give him a little
heads up like that and we don't see this
bumpy it's silent i'm like hey i warmed
him up for you i just patted him on the
yeah
you had him on the head and made him
feel good and i go can i finish one time